WE ALL HAVE MOMENTS IN LIFE WHEN
WE WAKE UP AND WE REALIZE THAT
OUR DREAMS AREN'T WORKING OUT.
PRACTICE ALL YOU WANT, YOU ARE
NOT GOING TO BE THE QUARTERBACK
FOR THE BIRDS.
>> HAVEN'T PLAYED IN YEARS.
WHY CAN'T I BE QUARTERBACK?
>> YOU ARE RIGHT.
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU'VE GOT.
HIT ME, I'M OPEN.
THAT'S WHY.
NOW SIT DOWN AND SHUT UP.
>> Jesse: AND YOU ARE NOT JUST
ONE BREAK AWAY FROM SCORING THAT
RECORD DEAL.
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> Jesse: RIGHT NOW, DEMOCRATS
ARE HAVING THAT MOMENT WITH THE
ECONOMY, THOUGH I DON'T THINK
JOE BIDEN REALIZES IT.
>> EMIGRANTS ARE WORKING TO
BRING DOWN THE COST OF THINGS,
TALK AROUND THE KITCHEN TABLE.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS AREN'T
WORKING TO BRING ANYTHING DOWN
EXCEPT TRUMP.
JOE BIDEN AND THE JIMMY CARTER
OF THE 21ST CENTURY HAS
DESTROYED YOUR MONEY.
FOUR DECADE HIGH, UP AGAIN FROM
SEPTEMBER.
YOUR 401(K) IS DOWN 25% THIS
YEAR.
DON'T EVEN LOOK AT IT.
YOU WILL JUST GET UPSET.
YOUR PAYCHECKS ARE BEING ROBBED
LIKE THEY ARE RIDING THE SUBWAY.
WAGES HAVE GONE DOWN EVERY
SINGLE MONTH JOE HAS BEEN IN
OFFICE.
LOOK AT THAT.
EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
BIDEN'S ECONOMY IS GARNISHING
YOUR WAGES LIKE YOU ARE A
CRIMINAL.
LOOK AT THAT FEAR OF OUR
PAYCHECKS EXPLODED UNDER TRUMP
AND HOW YOUR MONEY IS CRASHING.
THE COST OF THINGS HAVE SHOT UP,
GROCERIES UP 20%, 20% INCREASE
IN ENERGY.
BIDEN IS BLOWING UP THE ECONOMY
LIKE IT IS A PIPELINE, AND HE IS
LIKE O.J., STILL SEARCHING FOR
THE REAL CULPRIT.
>> THE BIGGEST PROBLEM IS THE
WORLD'S CHALLENGE, GLOBAL
INFLATION, AND THE PANDEMIC, AND
PUTIN'S UNCONSCIONABLE INVASION
OF UKRAINE.
>> Jesse: BUT IF YOU STRIP THE
POLITICS OUT OF IT LIKE THEY DO
ON WALL STREET, IT IS BENIGN AND
THE DEMOCRATS FAULT.
BUT THE EXPERTS AT
MORGAN STANLEY, THEY GET IT.
THEY SAY THIS FEAR BREAKS AS A
FISCAL STIMULUS PROVIDED DURING
THE PANDEMIC, PARTICULARLY THE
LAST
$1.9 TRILLION PACKAGE, AT
THE
END OF MARCH 2021, JUST AS THE
ECONOMY -- IN OUR VIEW, THIS IS
WHAT TURBOCHARGED CONSUMPTION
AND DROVE INFLATION TO
FORTY-YEAR HIGHS.
SO THE $2 TRILLION COVID RELIEF
BILL THAT DIDN'T PROVIDE ANY
RELIEF SINCE EVERYBODY CAUGHT
COVID, A BILL THAT NOT A SINGLE
REPUBLICAN VOTED FOR
TURBOCHARGED PRICES.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS AT LEAST WE ARE DOING
BETTER THAN VENEZUELA.
NOT EVEN CNN IS BUYING THAT.
>> THERE IS NO WAY TO REALLY
SUGARCOAT THIS REPORT.
PRICES ROSE 8.2%.
WHAT IS THE ADMINISTRATION DOING
AND WHAT CAN THE ADMINISTRATION
DO, ASIDE FROM JUST TELLING
AMERICANS TO BE PATIENT AT THIS
POINT.
>> THE FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT
POINT IS THE UNITED STATES IS IN
A BETTER AND STRONGER POSITION
TO TAKE THIS CHALLENGE HEAD ON
THAN VIRTUALLY ANY OTHER COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD.
>> BRIAN, JUST TELLING AMERICANS
THINGS AREN'T AS BAD HERE AS
THEY ARE AROUND THE WORLD ISN'T
A REASSURING STATEMENT.
>> Jesse: AMERICAS AND A
STRONGER POSITION THAN
BANGLADESH.
THAT IS THEIR TALKING POINT.
IMAGINATIVE DURING KATRINA, BUSH
SAID YEAH COME OF THE FLOOR
FRENCH QUARTER IS FLOODED --
EVERYONE KNOWS RECESSION IS
COMING, EVEN THE DEMOCRATS.
BIDEN THINK IT IS A SLIGHT
RECESSION, LOSE YOUR JOB IT MAY
BE KEEP HOUSE.
DON'T WORRY, THE DEMOCRATS HAVE
A PLAN.
THEY ARE GOING TO BLAME THE
RECESSION ON THE REPUBLICANS.
>> THE REPUBLICANS HAVE EXPLICIT
INCENTIVE TO MAKE THE ECONOMY
WORSE, AND I WILL TELL YOU,
HAVING COVERED THE TEA PARTY
CONGRESS IN 2011 AMID THE
RECOVERY OF A FINANCIAL CRISIS,
IF THE REPUBLICANS WIN CONTROL
OF ONE OR BOTH HOUSES OF
CONGRESS, THEY WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO
SABOTAGE THE ECONOMY, TO BEST
SET THEM UP TO RETAKE THE
WHITE HOUSE IN 2024.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN MUST HAVE
WATCHED THAT GUY, WHO IDENTIFIES
AS MADDOW, AND PLAGIARIZED HIM.
>> IF REPUBLICANS WIN, INFLATION
WILL GET WORSE.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
>> AND IT'S LIKE SAYING IF THE
REPUBLICANS WIN, PUTIN IS GOING
TO INVADE UKRAINE.
HE ALREADY DID.
HOW CAN BANKRUPT THE COUNTRY OF
JOE ALREADY DID IT, CAN'T GET
WORSE THAN THIS.
THE ECONOMY IS THE NUMBER ONE
ISSUE IN THE COUNTRY AND THE
DEMOCRATS NEVER TALK ABOUT IT.
THEY THINK THEY CAN JUST
SUGARCOAT A RECESSION AND HOPE
YOU DO NOT NOTICE.
>> WHEN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, IN
POLL AFTER POLL, THINK THAT THE
ECONOMY, THINK THAT INFLATION
ARE THE TWO MAJOR ISSUES, YOU
CANNOT IGNORE THOSE ISSUES.
>> Jesse: WELL, IF YOU PUNCH
SOMEONE IN THE FACE AND STOLE
THEIR WALLET, WOULD YOU BE ABLE
TO LOOK THEM IN THE I?
NO.
THAT IS WHY THE DEMOCRATS CAN'T
BE STRAIGHT WITH YOU.
THE DEMOCRATS LOST OUR MONEY AND
NOW THEY ARE LOSING OUR MINDS.
THEY HAVE COMPLETELY LOST THE
PLOT FEAR OF INSTEAD OF
ATTACKING INFLATION, THEY ARE
ATTACKING TRUMP.
THE DEMOCRATS DECIDED TO HOLD A
JANUARY 6TH HEARING TODAY.
THE SAME DAY THE INFLATION
NUMBER PRINTED.
WHAT HAPPENED AT TODAY'S
HEARING?
WELL, THEY VOTED TO SUBPOENA
TRUMP, A SLICK LITTLE STUNT TO
DISTRACT YOU FROM THE ECONOMIC
PAIN AND TRY TO BLOW OUT TODAY'S
INFLATION HEADLINES.
FOR A PARTY THAT CLAIMS THEY
DON'T WANT TO FIGHT CULTURE
WARS, THEIR ENTIRE MIDTERM
MESSAGE IS TRUMP AND ABORTION.
AGAIN, WHEN YOU LOSE CNN, YOU
ARE LOST.
CNN WROTE A PIECE ENTITLED
"VOTERS MAY CARE MORE ABOUT THE
COST OF FRENCH FRIES IN
JANUARY 6TH PANELS COMPELLING
EVIDENCE."
THEY EVEN WROTE THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE U.S.
CAPITOL INSURRECTION LONG AGO
DROPPED THE NOTION OF BEING A
NARROWLY FOCUSED QUEST FOR THE
FACTS.
IT IS HARD NOT TO SEE THURSDAYS
JANUARY 6TH HEARING AS AN
INTERVENTION IN THE MIDTERMS.
JOE BIDEN IS THREATENING TO
WITHHOLD MILITARY AID FROM AN
ALLY, SAUDI ARABIA, UNTIL THEY
DO HIM A POLITICAL FAVOR.
PUMP MORE OIL BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS TO HELP DEMOCRATS.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO HIDE THEIR RECORD FROM
YOU, THE VOTER.
THEY WILL EVEN PUT AN ALLY'S
NATIONAL SECURITY AT RISK TO
KEEP THE SENATE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS IMPEACHABLE.
BUT THEY SAY THE JANUARY 6TH
HEARINGS ARE NOT ABOUT POLITICS
OR PARTY.
>> INVESTIGATION IS NOT ABOUT
POLITICS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT PARTY.
IT'S ABOUT THE FACTS.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE.
>> Jesse: SINCE WHEN DO
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT FINDING THE
FACTS.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT LOOKED
BACK AND INVESTIGATED ANYTHING,
THE ORIGINS OF COVID, WHAT CHINA
HAS ON THE BIDENS, WHAT HAPPENED
IN AFGHANISTAN FOR TWO DECADES.
WHERE THE MONEY WENT THAT WE
SENT TO THE TEACHERS UNIONS, THE
RUSSIA HOAX, HOW EPSTEIN MADE
HIS CASH, WHY CRIME IS SURGING.
WHERE ARE THE 20,000 UNDER WAGE
ILLEGALS WENT TO THAT BIDEN
LOST.
THE DEMOCRATS SAYING STRONG
DEMOCRACY ON JANUARY 6TH, 2021,
BUT IT HAPPENED EARLIER THAN
THAT, ON OCTOBER 14TH, 2020,
WHEN "THE NEW YORK POST"
BOMBSHELL STORY ON THE BIDEN
CRIME FAMILY WAS SUPPRESSED BY
THE MEDIA.
THE FBI AND OTHER POWERFUL
INTERESTS, WHICH ALLOWED
JOE BIDEN TO WIN THE ELECTION.
THE SURVEYS ALL SHOW, SWING
STATE VOTERS HAD BEEN AWARE OF
IT, ENOUGH VOTES WOULD HAVE GONE
TO TRUMP, SWINGING THE ELECTION
TRUMP'S FAVOR.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE AN ASSAULT
ON OUR DEMOCRACY?
YEAH.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
INVESTIGATE JANUARY 6TH BECAUSE
THEY DON'T THINK THEY HAVE ANY
FINGERPRINTS ON IT, BUT THEY
KNOW THEY ARE COMPLICIT.
THEY KNOW WHAT THEY DID TO THE
REPUBLICAN OCTOBER SURPRISE,
UNLEASH THE RAGE WE SAW THAT
DAY.
AND WE KNOW THAT THIS MIDTERM
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
JANUARY 6TH.
THAT DAY DOES NOT AFFECT THE
LIVES OF VOTERS TODAY.
DEMOCRATS KNOW THEY ARE ABOUT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY ARE
PANICKING.
WE ARE GOING TO LOOK INTO EVERY
CREVICE, CHECK UNDER EVERY BED,
LOOK AT EVERY SINGLE WITNESS,
LOOK AT EVERY BANK TRANSACTION,
AND EXPOSED EVERY SING